there's no reason to assume that 20  years ago we reached some extraordinary  level of sexual activity I think sex is  a is a is a kind of activity that people  who are pursuing an interesting fun  exciting optimistic life is something  that they pursue I think that  particularly among young today I mean  this seems to be a pretty negative  generation uh you know everybody's  convinced the world is about to end uh  people think that there are these  profound problems and issues all around  the world that they live in the worst of  times I think that kind of attitude  towards life is something that reduces  one sex urges I think sex is something  that one pursues when one feels good  about life when one feels good about  one's own opportunities in life it's a  profound both physical and spiritual  experience of pleasure and optimism and  celebration of life I mean sex is the  ultimate celebration of being alive